in the 80s when all the [ __ ] metal
bands were you know wearing spandex
was there any pressure on you from
management from metallica to
be more commercially successful by like
you know wearing like
like long like i don't know robes or you
know what i mean like
how did you avoid that pressure our
managers were
looking after dawkin remember them yeah
dawkin
and we were the anthesis to that we were
the opposite and
they were actually fiercely protective
of us we started in la
so it's 1981. we're starting to play a
few shows up in hollywood and everything
that was playing up on
sunset boulevard at you know the whiskey
and troubadour
and gazaris and all those were all those
bands that had that
image and it fueled us it made us want
to be the opposite to that
and all those other bands that was just
that was the the enemy the opposition
that was who stood in our way
when you talk about the fueling see this
is something i relate to
when i got into my radio career i was an
angry [ __ ]
as far as i was concerned everyone else
on the radio was [ __ ] this was my
attitude
have you ever gone back and had to
apologize to other bands that you
worked with on tour because you guys
were angry and pissed
i know that anger you have to have it if
you're going to succeed
it's it's you've got to have you have
you have yeah
incidents but there was a lot of bands
that you know
were talking crap about us you know
right which actually
helped us in a way too you know and then
we'd actually end up touring with some
of those bands like
you know motley crue yeah they're being
in there oh uh
i'm sorry about what i said in that uh
that cream magazine interviews like
oh well thank you i didn't read it but
thank you we had a we had a tour book i
think it was on the black album tour we
found
every single [ __ ] negative nasty
quote that anybody had ever said about
metallica
and there was a lot of them and we put
them all in that tour book and some of
them were me
and it was just kind of the way
that we would just get kind of back at
these people you know in the nothing
else matters video
we had a dart board and there's a clip
in that video where i'm throwing darts
at a picture of kip winger remember kid
yeah yeah and listen still to this day
i i feel like uh i i apologize to
you know whenever it's brought up in
interviews it's like there's nothing
against kid winger personally
but uh kind of like what you're saying
it 35 years later it feels awkward
to sit and talk about that but you can't
deny that when you're
18 and full full of spunk and venom and
and just
wanted to [ __ ] the whole world you know
it does drive you it does
drive you and and and it it it it's an
incredible drive you know
i love what you're saying howard because
it's true that uh
should i have been that way should i
have been different no
it happened because it happened and it
had to happen to get where we are right
now
to respect the past and to respect our
enemy and all of the things that fueled
us and brought us to where we are now
and you know uh as you might know you
know the first half of your life is
causing destruction and the second half
of your life is maybe
cleaning a bit of it up you know right